[Musique]
j'étais à paris je ne mens pas français
je suis rentré j'ai préparé et je
voulais finir 4 heures à pondre ses
pages sur la tectonique des plaques
elle était assise de maurice et en
regardant le ciel contemplant
l'éventualité où le rate mon bac et les
conséquences pour sage à l'époque
désastreuse que ça aurait surgi quand
une femme bien s'arrêter devant moi pour
me demander si je parle arabe avec ma
fierté de moitié maghrébine
je dis pas ouais et hermétique il
entretint passer un casting pour le
premier rôle d'un long métrage
et si ça m'intéressait de passer
l'audition des jours plus tard je me
retrouve dans un bureau à jouer pour la
toute première fois de ma vie que la
cena d'émouvantes j'étais une d'émotions
les larmes aux yeux
c'est la première phase a marié vénaux
et ça n'a pas loupé mon talent brut fait
son effet on le rappelle on va me revoir
et bien colbac la rizza trice veut me
rencontrer
j'arrive avant maintenant j'ai compris
tu rentres fier de moi
je me suis dit je me suis dis gamin
c'est une histoire qu'on entend juste là
au yacht
je n'arrive pas dans la vraie vie je me
suis dit voyez déjà une pâleur zoo
journalistes sortez noël on va découvrir
mon lycée c'est comme ça tu devenu
artiste un peuple en ses rivaux coleman
je me rappelle plus trop ce qui s'est
passé parce que je me rappelle ces
canaris that he is elle est sortie de la
grèce de hervé renoh tellement un trail
j'ai quand même à l'époque j'avais dit
sur roanne n'arrivait pas à parler
j'étais prendre un vice donc du coup si
de marina les parents ne m'a plus jamais
craquelé vent de l'histoire
c'est le film
[Applaudissements]
une saison c'est dans ce blog on va par
les scientifiques
c'est ce que l'on pense que le choix
d'une carrière est déterminé par la
classe sociale règlement m'appartient
d'accord certains écrits de la
profession de leur père de lambert
d'autres choses grandes filières qui en
accord avec les valeurs de leurs parents
d'autres encore sera influencée par le
foie d'éducation qui saura donc pas
encore le nom d'une famille marocaine de
classe moyenne de côté de ma mère et
d'une famille d'ouvriers portugais du
côté de mon père mon choix s'est orienté
vers la médecine
d'ailleurs si on écoute tous les parents
marocains on serait tous médecins
opérant aux ingénieurs c'était mon cas
ma mère ne voyais en blouse blanche
le cpo scop autour du cou chirurgien de
renom je perdais toute la famille
gratuit et je voyais que les invités de
la maison je voyais le regard fier de ma
mère quand on me demander ce que je
voulais être quand je sors est grande et
que je répondais chirurgien du coeur
c'est pour ça que je suis un bac
scientifique et et que j'étais lancer
une carrière passionnés dans dans le
monde des maladies cardiovasculaires
infarctus du myocarde prescription et
tutti quanti
mais ça c'était avant
quand la femme et je viens me parler
devant le lycée
interroge les reds l'air en ulm se
posaient de longs mois est ce que je
devais faire une carrière pour laquelle
je ne ressentais rien et qui en quelque
sorte on appartenait pas et qui n'existe
qu'à travers le regard de ma mère ou de
neige utilisée par celle pour laquelle
je ressentis soudainement une forte
émotion et au risque de décevoir ma mère
l'a rentré en conflit faire face à
l'incompréhension totale parce que
j'avais c'était la première fois que
j'ai exprimé un désir artistique
si on compte pas la droit mon 3 contre
l'islam
j'avais 11 ans j'étais extrêmement
timide mais je suis est parti de là près
du collège j ai je rêvé d'être chanteuse
donc du coup je prends mon courage à
deux mains je vais poser ma mère dans ma
chambre et je lui chante
à l'époque d'une chanson très populaire
qui s'appelle ma meilleure amie de l'eau
rire j'avoue j'aurais pu faire un autre
choix mais je la chante devant le maire
devait fermer les yeux je suis passionné
j'aime france
et quand je
je vois le regard dépité de ma mère qui
se lève et sort de la chambre
[Applaudissements]
là j'ai compris que ma carrière de
chanteuse pop définit donc j'avais plus
amusant ce parler j'ai tiré tant qu est
ce qu on fait un choix professionnel
pour nos parents ou pour nous mêmes
et qu'est ce qu'on veut quand on soigne
un métier une reconnaissance sociale
une passion l'argent frais une
stimulation intellectuelle tout à la
fois pour moi je ne supportait pas
l'idée que je fasse quelque chose qui ne
me plaisent pas l'idée de rester ou
d'être dans un endroit où je ne suis je
ne voulais pas être que le restant de
mes jours ça m'angoissait d'ailleurs je
comprenais pas pourquoi les gens de ma
carrière
ça devait dépendre de quelqu'un d'autre
pour moi je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
on fait la vie de quelqu'un d'autre
devrait interférer sur le choix de ma
carrière de monde de ma vie donc du coup
je suis la france est de plus en plus à
ce nouveau hobby trouvait devant mon
lycée et j'ai décidé d'investir sans
permis science secrètement il partie de
l'argent envoyé ma mère par mois pour
des cons du soir au théâtre et la charge
de travail et elle en fait que j'ai fait
un bon match je suis tombé malade
compris
pourquoi et j'ai dû lui l'oeuvre dit
quand ma mère que je voulais faire du
théâtre c'est dévêtir que je ne voulais
pas étudié premièrement c'est plus
socialement inacceptable deuxièmement
qu'est ce que j'allais devenir sans
diplôme moi je voudrais me marier très
rapidement sinon je livrais dans la
misère se tenait mais dans les petites
filles pour ma santé est un gros
chantage émotionnel problème j'avoue ma
mère a fini par accepter elle pensait
que c'est ton presque comme quand volet
qui entonneront donc pas la suite quand
les invités venus à la maison et qui m'a
demandé qu'est ce que je faisais il y
avait toujours ce moment de gêne chez ma
mère quand je disais théâtre elle tirer
tous dans la tête du genre qu'est ce que
j'y pense white house un fait c'est pas
un grand choix
je suis très rapidement rendu compte que
le fait j'avais fait n'était pas le plus
facile
pas plus facile mais c'est notre cas
mais les trois ans de cours de théâtre à
paris on y roule t un enfer jeunes
cadres et nulle part du groupe des cours
de diction parce que mon accent les
dépasser parisien pour les textes de
molière
je le dépasse et jamais le premier tour
du concours du conservatoire national de
paris ni d'aucun autre concours
d'ailleurs un moment donné j'avais
trouvé un agent a rappelé mais à
l'entrée de son bureau elle le dit je
cite il va falloir que tu te mettes à la
tomate et salade verte ma vieille parce
que apparemment je ne trouvais pas de
travail
le tour de hanches que laver et que j'ai
toujours dû me lever tous d'accord 6
heures du matin pour faire voter ce
décret si vous n'avez pas ce que c'est
qu'un gars qui va vous tenez pas les
traits s est pas un jour c'est ça tous
les matins pour arrondir les fins de
mois y en même temps j'ai possédé des
castings pour déroule de colza que je
n'étais pas exulté crochet et derrière
j'avais ma mère dit qu'à chaque fois que
je parlais et que josé le plan de me
disais qu'il reprend pas limités dont le
ras-le-bol général j'ai visité le pari
ce n'était pas pour moi j'ai les parents
de côté je suis parti quatre mois en
inde du sud est tout seul mon sac à dos
pour me rafraîchir les idées aux
revenants je me suis dit je l'aï
installé un autre là bas les gens sont
cons donc direction de londres à
l'époque le seul truc que je pouvais
m'offrir le seul truc que je pouvais
m'offrir en fait comme voyez c'était une
petite cabane au fond d'un jardin dans
une maison d'une famille de sept membres
avec qui je partage et que sa salle de
bain du coup mon accent parisien si
durement acquis est mon anglais plutôt
bancale mon permis aux débuts de travail
que dans des bars chez miche ne fait pas
démonté moi je me démoralise par gmail
travaillée retravaillée en axant pour
avoir un accent anglais
je me suis teint en blonde pour faire
plus européenne je me suis même devenu
un million vegan stadium quand tu mange
des graines d'une guerre et de légumes
crus j'étais déterminé je voulais
m'intégrer mais rien n'y fait je ne
pensais jamais pour une anglaise où il
avait trouvé un agent moment donné je
décrochais cours des ultimes et dans les
pubs ont demandé de regarder la barre de
rire avec un regard bovin en prétendant
avoir le qi d'une huître
c'est désagréable 10 ans peut-elle --où
matin je reçois un mail de mon agent qui
me dit va chercher quelqu'un d'autre qui
aura un regard plus vrai sur la
situation
autre échec autre rejet autre coup de
tonnerre
donc je ne suis pas sorti suite à ça
dans ma chambre pendant ce séjour à
pleurer et ranger du gras et du sucre et
gym ou di natale qui était venue de
vandaliser pour le ver changé le cours
de ma vie quand j'ai repris mes esprits
et quelques kilos
je suis sur un fil du temps à un gars
qui dit qu'on put bert à seppois et
l'agilité se doivent donc j'ai décidé de
me reconnecter avec des sauces et de
repenser ma situation
le maroc direction casamance j'ai pris
un billet j'avais quelques bouquets j'ai
eu cinq rendez vous avec 5 très beau
réateur marocain
mais comment vous de postes d'internés
sol j'ai donné pour ce financier mondial
et pas de boulot pour moi pour les deux
trois prochaines années
je redoute retourne donc dans tes bras
et à ce moment là franchement j'aurais
pu la faire mais je ne sais pas pourquoi
il y avait une voix dans ma tête qui lui
disait n'abandonne pas malgré tout les
noms que je rappelais je savais
pertinemment qu'il y avait un mot qui
l'attendaient quelque part moi c'était
impossible que je travaille autant et
que je donne autant de ma personne
extérieure ça ne paye pas un moment
donné donc à force d'acharnement de lire
des livres sur le set développment de
m'entraîner tout seul avec ma caméra
dans ma chambre et d'envoyer 10 heures
et des organes d email
j'ai réussi à décrocher un second rôle
dans un long métrage anglais qui à ma
grande surprise a fait son petit bruit à
l'échelle internationale dans l'anecdote
dans le film je parle comme ça avec cet
accent rail va voir un voyou nous et ça
surtout théorie on dirait un travail et
mon accent ça n'a servi strictement à
rien
donc après je reçois un appel gardes
mobiles vient passer un casting pour le
premier rôle dans un long métrage
marocain
j'étais comme une peinture est un vivier
j'ai travaillé j'ai bûché commune
pendant six semaines pour décrocher le
rôle
et enfin je suprise est là et c'est là
qu'ils valent de jacques brel résonne en
moi
le talent n'existe pas
le talent c'est d'avoir envie et dieu
que j'en avais envie pour la tomate et
il ne pouvait pas mourir avant que je
dise la planète entière que j'ai une vie
de mon métier
et quand je pense juste et hôtesses
d'accueil
j'ai fait distributrice de players dans
la rue j'étais par mail
j'ai fait figure entier quand tu payes
trois ans de théâtre et que tu te
retrouves à marcher derrière les
comédiens comme ça je vais te dire que
ça c'est certain malaise
j'ai fait tout ça mais ça m'a appris
beaucoup sur madrid sur mon métier sur
ce que je ne veux pas faire sur ce que
je ne veux pas le faire sur ce que je
vois en durée pour ce que je souhaite
vraiment mais par dessus tout j'ai
accepté contre la vigie des vols et
j'étais une artiste une comédienne et
que j'étais pigiste et ça me dire
marocaine portugaise arabe h
eurocoupe et que j'en étais hier
quoi tu montres étaient tellement à
vouloir changer donc ma conclusion dans
tout ça vous faites ce que vous êtes
ne prétendez pas être quelqu'un d'autre
mais n'essayez pas de vous mettre dans
la poche de quelqu'un d'autre
tout le monde finira pas vous accepter
si vous commencez à vous acceptez vont
mettre la vie de deux ans un million de
raisons de tout abandonner et de lâcher
un verre mais il y aura toujours une
raison qui consisterait à confier c'est
celle que j'ai écouté et aujourd'hui je
vis de mon métier
quand très souvent je pensais que
j'allais rester dans une cabane au fond
d'un jardin et enfin pour terminer j'ai
toujours une petite pensée émue pour la
femme qui revient devant mon lycée vont
pas passer mon premier casting parce
qu'elle m'a ouvert les yeux sur un
nouveau monde sur un tas de possibilités
de changement et d'évolution
voilà
[Applaudissements]